estamos en la universidad del valle aquí
en cali la ciudad vuelve a vivir un paro
nacional este miércoles y en las calles
lo que hemos podido comprobar es que hay
nutrida presencia de personas en los
distintos puntos de bloqueo que en la
ciudad han estado dominando desde el 28
de abril aquí en la universidad del
valle justo ahora se va a marchar la
minga indígena donde hay 5 mil personas
si lo hacen por cuestiones de seguridad
antes de irse eso sí van a visitar los
distintos puntos del bloqueo de los
distintos puntos de resistencia que han
estado bloqueando en las últimas semanas
cabe destacar también quien les han
acompañado el presidente de la comisión
de la verdad francisco de rucks así como
las naciones unidas también a las 2 de
la tarde en otros puntos en puerto
resistencia a uno de los más nutridos va
a ver una performance a las 2 de la
tarde que se va a repetir en otras
ciudades de colombia y también del mundo
para homenajear a los muertos que ha
habido en las protestas también desde la
alcaldía france24 nos ha confesado que
por la tarde va a haber una reunión
entre el presidente iván duque con la
gobernación la alcaldía y parte del
comité de paro así como manifestantes
que han estado
protagonizando estos bloqueos de la
ciudad desde el 28 de abril en colombia